like Backstreet abortions and illegal
abortions or whatever
I sure Naturally that that might happen
but I also think it's possible that if
women don't have the option for abortion
it'll be they might be more careful
because you can you imagine like if if
we were living like how we all are today
um and like let's say like you go out
clubbing you find someone you have a
one-night stand or whatever like I don't
know like contraception because I'm not
feeling like oh my God like if I had to
go in for an abortion like I just think
the fear of that like I think over the
last three years I've certainly gathered
that fear controls people and fear like
instills certain papers in people and I
think by not having the option for
abortion generally speaking say 99 of
the time I think women would just sort
of wise up we're not silly if you know
that it's going to be difficult to do
something you'd avoid doing anything
that would lead to that being the
consequence that's just what I think